we now continue with the development of
continuous analogs of everything we know
for the discrete case we have already
seen a few versions of the total
probability theorem one version for
events and one version for pmfs let us
now develop a continuous analogue
suppose as always that we have a
partition of the sample space into a
number of disjoint scenarios three
scenarios in this picture more general
en scenarios in these formulas let's X
be a continuous random variable and let
us take B to be the event that the
random variable takes a value less than
or equal to some little X by the total
probability theorem this is the
probability of the first scenario times
the conditional probability of this
event given that the first scenario has
materialized and then we have similar
terms for the other scenarios let us now
turn this equation into CDF notation the
left hand side is what we have defined
as the CDF of the random variable X on
the right hand side what we have is the
probability of the first scenario
multiplied again by a CDF of the random
variable X but it is a CDF that applies
in a conditional model where event a 1
has occurred and so we use this notation
to denote the conditional CDF the CDF
that applies to the conditional universe
and then we have similar terms for the
other scenarios now we know that the
derivative of a CDF is a PDF we also
know that any general fact such as this
one that applies to unconditional models
will also apply without change to a
conditional model because a conditional
model is just like any other ordinary
probability model so let us now take
derivatives of both sides of this
equation on the left hand side we have
the derivative of a CDF which is a PDF
and on the right hand side we have the
probability of the first scenario and
then the derivative of the conditional
CDF
which has to be the same as the
conditional PDF so we use here the fact
that derivatives of CD f's are PDFs and
then we have similar terms under the
different scenarios so we now have a
relation between densities to interpret
this relation we think as follows the
probability of falling inside the little
interval around X is determined by the
probability of falling inside that
little interval under each one of the
different scenarios and where each
scenario is weighted by the
corresponding probability now we
multiply both sides of this equation by
X and then integrate over all X's we do
this on the left-hand side and similarly
on the right-hand side to obtain a term
of this form and we have similar terms
corresponding to the other scenarios
what do we have here on the left-hand
side we have the expected value of x on
the right hand side we have this
probability multiplied by the
conditional expectation of x given that
scenario a 1 has occurred and so we
obtain a version of the total
expectation theorem it's exactly the
same formula as we had in the discrete
case except that now X is a continuous
random variable let us now look at a
simple example that involves a model
with different scenarios Bill wakes up
in the morning and wants to go to the
supermarket there are two scenarios with
probability 1/3 the first scenario
occurs and under that scenario bill will
go at a time that's uniformly
distributed between 0 and 2 hours from
now so the conditional PDF of X in this
case is uniform on the interval from
zero to two
there's a second scenario that bill will
take a long nap and will go later in the
day that scenario has a probability of
2/3 and under that case the conditional
PDF of X is going to be uniform on the
range between 6 & 8 by the total
probability theorem for densities the
density of X of the random variable the
time at which he goes to the supermarket
consists of two pieces one piece is a
uniform between 0 & 2
this uniform ordinarily would have a
height of 1/2 on the other hand it gets
weighted by the corresponding
probability which is 1/3 so we obtain a
piece here that has a height of 1/6
under the alternative scenario the
conditional density is a uniform on the
interval between 6 & 8 this uniform has
a height of 1/2 again but it gets
multiplied by a factor of 2/3
and this results in a height for this
term that we have here which is 1/3 and
this is the form of the PDF of the time
and which bill will go to the
supermarket we can now finally use the
total expectation theorem the
conditional expectation under the two
scenarios can be found as follows under
one scenario we have a uniform between 0
& 2 and so the conditional expectation
is 1 and it gets weighted by the
corresponding probability which is 1/3
under the second scenario which probably
which has probability 2/3 the
conditional expectation is the midpoint
of this uniform which is 7 and this
gives us the expected value of the time
at which we go so this is a simple
example but it illustrates nicely how we
can construct a model that involves a
number of different scenarios and by
knowing the probability distribution
under
one of the scenarios we can find the
probability distribution overall and we
can also find the expected value for the
overall experiment